e aí galera que assistiu nada vocês vai
pedir uma coisa que é muito importante
que você clique em gostei entendeu
entender o que é chato você assistiu o
vídeo e e ensaia aqui não gosta a gente
até comenta e nunca gostei então já vai
ficando mais gostei aí que o negócio a
monges é com vocês podem ver eu não
estou na minha casa eu estou aqui pra lá
que eu tô em minas gerais
tô aqui na terra do pt de varginha
chegando aqui eu comecei a pegar um
negócio de família de novo de sentar na
mesa começa com as pessoas e aí eu
lembrei que eu moro sozinho eu moro
sozinho tem vezes que é bom assim todo
mundo anda é muito bom essa ideia muito
como nação independente de onde você
mora meu exemplo eu eu moro numa
quitinete sapec net pra você que não
sabe o que é uma quitinete um quitinete
com um apartamento só que pobre e que
tinha geralmente é muito pequenininho
que era ligada tipo tenha um banheiro o
quarto a sozinha e cabul eo hamas não
tem sala na verdade tem sala só que é o
seguinte tem a geladeira e um fogão é
você vira de costas
então na verdade não tem isso não se
imagina que ali tem uma sala entendeu
mora sozinho talvez não seja tão legal
ao todo mundo pensa por exemplo cara
perde o horário até que todas as sete
horas para quando 8 mm além do cara
coloca o celular em cima da cama eu por
exemplo tenho uma chance lá em cima na
cama e quando a conta com testar duas um
homem nesta começou lá
ouça lá esbagaçados só que eu já tenho
uma técnica tão negativo toda vez que eu
vou dormir agora bota o celular no modo
avião à noite ele cai da cama está
voando também tem uma coisa ruim que
você morar sozinha a questão da
arrumação
você às vezes se esquece de fazer as
coisas e esquece dobrar a roupa se
esquecem de lavar louça e esquecer da
valor pra quem mora só é um grande
problema por exemplo é ficar rouca
esquece de lavar o copo na escala é o
que ela desgraça prega no fundo aquilo
ali e você pode esfregar os e esfrega
sai a alma do copo
há um défice tal não sai com os punhos
cara esquece construir no prato depois
lavar mas você pode esfregar vocês
pregos e arranco pra da pia mas não
arranca a desgraça do escudo para agora
tem uma coisa boa em você esquecer a
louça suja por exemplo em casa tem o
souza tem um mês que está sujo o que é
que eu faço faço
calendar meu deus que dia é hoje talvez
copinha ficar aqui eu tomei na
sexta-feira e se com as coisas aqui ou
combina terça feira que foi antes de
ontem então ontem foi 4 já quinta feira
aí pra você fazer calendário usui às
vezes tenho saudade de casa nessa de ser
criança de novo tá ligado e dormindo só
foi abordado na cama com saudade de
dormir no sofá e acordar
eu estou falando isso porque hoje eu sou
grande o dono do software podem só falam
do flamengo é porque não tem um sofá que
tanto sofre não só agora não pense você
que porque eu moro sozinho minha
geladeira só tem porcaria não está
ligado na geladeira é muito saudável
veja bem a minha maneira tem uma
melancia uma maçã sucesso é aquele de
coca cola 4 quilo de beco ainda tem 12
que ele presente que eu comprei ontem eu
acho que eu vou ter até que tirar essa
melancia de mas continua saudável mas
depois você morar na quitinete quitinete
é muito pequenininha aí facilita a
interação entre vôos e os vizinhos
ligaram eu tô lá de bolavam na outra eu
escutava escutando calypso e escutou do
vizinho lado cantando lá para rachada eu
escuto vivem do outro lado escutando
djavú aconselhar a qualidade da
variedade musical é erótico de imóvel é
muito pequeno mas muito que me ligado eu
só com perda de 50 pode
o foco foi então que quem podia deixar
tomando banho escorreguei é o caymmi
quando eu caí ficou com um pé no
banheiro na barriga na sala eo braço na
cozinha aproveitei a derrota estragado
na escala talvez aí esfregue acordo com
os clubes abrir nova geladeira também 92
qualquer cota ficar beleza né isso é uma
maravilha para falar a verdade não tenho
do que reclamar de morar só eu gosto
porque porque eu morar só eu posso eu
quiser posso concordar com uma hora da
tarde eu posso apelar pela casa e aí vou
fazer o quê vão bater combater foi muito
menor carvão porque eu moro sozinha e
quem paga é quem eu e aí só lembrando
que se você gostou desse vídeo clique
aqui e gostei faça um favor pra mim por
favor deus me ajuda muito e eu quero que
você comente aqui em baixo o que você
gostaria de fazer se você morasse só e o
que você faz se você já mora só se você
quiser receber vídeos desse canal os
meus vídeos assistir mais vídeos só se
aplica a quem escrevesse toda vez que
tiver um globo você vai saber já clique
em compartilhar no facebook
você compartilha pode assim origem mas
que minha sabe esse é meu twitter e esse
é meu facebook esse é o instagram essas
três redes sociais é sempre coloco
quando tem vídeo novo então é só você
ficar ligado porque segui lá acompanha
assim e fique ligado o exemplo e minas
gerais agora invadem e muitos de vocês
não sabiam porquê porque não tão ligado
no facebook ou no twitter
o número está gamboa gente quer pedir um
favorzinho pra vocês a minha amiga
gisele soares que essa moça aqui ela
está participando do concurso da vip das
100 mulheres mais sexies da terra da
terra
acho que ela tem nome pode ser do ar né
eu queria pedir para você votar nela
você vai no site que tem a descrição do
vídeo aí vai aparecer cinco coisas lá e
você coloca a dizer lá em primeiro e
escreve senão tite deve soares e e
coloca outras cinco pessoas aleatórias
em baixa e volta eu sou do piauí ela do
piauí eu quero ajudar ela porque a gente
da terra é isso aí muito obrigado por
ter assistido esse vídeo até aqui vocês
são um massa de mais gostei comentou se
inscreve compartilha curso a postar no
facebook e é isso aí falou